I have a question for the parents in the
room there's only two oh you and you
know you two I was only three asking the
question that's not the point
yeah okay well we don't know all the
kids Joe's got up and she sounds like
such a mom right now okay parents are
the room does take a color with crayons
yep what a nerd what is these really
draw new scribbles
Oh okey suds - oh yeah get him he draws
the horror movie design jokers that's so
funny okay so turns out that Crayola has
now been launched a brand deal for tyka
congratulation watches off its coloring
books with no lines just with little
kids I guess is there's the page just a
blank page for creative kids blank pages
I like that idea
okay well Crayola has announced a new
set of crayons that will represent 40
different skin tones oh I saw this yeah
colors of the world it sounds [ __ ]
lame it's cool but I don't want some a
Joyce it's like as a kid just give me
the basic choices so I can bike just get
to 24 colors of skin look I love it but
first can we do so that if they get all
over the fridge it washes off easy
that's the main water base I think all
the rug though cuz they're wax the
residue bro no you gotta get a pencil
eraser it will come off or you have to
get a freakin oh my god hairdryer - oh
man - yeah that's why they should do
work on this first I don't know it says
my crazy I like the magic ones where
it's all white you don't see [ __ ] and
it's not the traces do
we're talking about multi skin colors
you talking about all white I knew your
one another clear one I accept you GL
fully well lean completely no I just see
different nipple colors Crayola smell
with three K's over here that's so true
Crayola crayon I like this idea I think
it's really cool because I know I like
you when you color and [ __ ] as a kid you
want to represent your own color you
want to do purple normal colored human
beads you want green humans purple
humans that's stupid that's you I miss
when all drawings were just yellow
people know what it's funny of you guys
okay look I know this feels almost
borderline like this is like annoyingly
to oak but also I remember being a
little kid coloring myself and be like
oh I'm not the same color as [ __ ]
Daniel Lange like why do we have to use
the same crazy orange orange yeah I feel
that
but uhm yeah they actually are working
with this guy his name is Victor Victor
Castle Victor Flint and he is a Mack
chief chemist and coverfx co-founder so
he works in makeup and so they they're
working with him they worked with him
over a nine-month process in order to
come out with this in time to celebrate
you know the diversity in colors are the
crayon colors actually like just
ethnicities like Pettis right here
what is the name or - white I was trying
to zoom in but it's too pixelated say
something yeah I couldn't read them
right Compton brown by you rap by you
brother Abraham no I can't read it
Egyptian tan because he víctimas saying
like he was so European yo he said
growing up I remember mixing the pink
and dark brown crayons to try to make my
shade so I was thrilled when Creoles
as for my help to create the colors of
the world's crayons if he had prism as I
believe yeah cuz those blend really well
but Crayola nah that's what they got to
figure out is I hated crayons as a kid
cuz they didn't have a consistent line
that [ __ ] was off [ __ ] bumpy yeah and
I would get so mad and then I found out
about pastel and I was like oh what is
this [ __ ] what do you mean was bumpy you
know that's all waxy so if you draw it's
like you'll be like oh you didn't got
you guys think it there's a box with a
sharpener at the end of it you know like
just the texture itself it's like kind
of like when you have to like really
smash that [ __ ] in to have a solid nice
like coda picture all your crayons like
this big y'all aren't finessing it
enough if you just hit it right
no I hit it oh I hit it real good oh
really it's like it was bumpy afterward
which is what people say when they hit
it real good no even like on Photoshop
and stuff when you use like that brush
or honest oh don't you think okay okay
okay I got welcome welcome
I understand that I understand now but
still use it the sharpener wood the
sharpener fix that hey what if you
sharpen it and I hit it real light and
it really I always go hard baby have you
guys ever [ __ ] with the watercolor
color pencils Oh what are you in little
water colored pencils by hitting it and
we talking about [ __ ] things why here
it's color pencil right it's a color
pencil and you shade it all in then you
get a wet brush and you brush it and it
looks like you did the whole lot of
mutters I thought you meant those those
brush pens were you it's like a pen cap
and you look and it is like a brush tip
at the end oh it's like watercolors and
then gel pen gel pens are good gel pens
are good yeah this is the cocaine
episode damn I wish I knew what they
were titled though
another one felt tips the [ __ ] both cuz
I feel like what did he really have to
do except for just take the old colors
and just like you'd be like hey this is
you know like you take the I don't know
caramel and be like label it and label
it light-skinned girl or something I'm
saying and you're thinking about kid
[ __ ] from adult point of view like if
you gave those crayons to a kid you buy
this is the most boring box of crayons
I've ever seen guys everything Brown
that's what I would say Yahtzee Brown
don't care dude that would actually be
way more creative because they're kind
of boring was it like Mukul
it's like medium deep roads light medium
almonds yeah they should have made it
like like Nordic white or like you don't
actually call it the the the lightest
superior race white or very light golden
very like Italian olives they're trying
to keep it as unproblematic as possible
about Imperial white Imperial that's a
really high shade of white like super
low do and how about colonial colonizer
white the whole box is just nothing but
white ones and then there's a there's a
poor whites to go far like poor whites
which is like a little bit of red on the
neck it's a freckled crayon surrounded
by the black bands in there you go it
smells kind of messy well it comes out
in fretful chlorine I appreciate it but
as a kid and nor to pick this up look
any of them look like the same color to
me nipples yeah I feel like as a kid I
would have like really not really cared
but as a maybe I don't know fourth
grader junior higher with my crayons I
would have appreciated this Wow
other pencils are the [ __ ] who uses
crayons after fourth grade even yeah
whoo baby [ __ ] well there's some late
people this one lady no but nobody you
know what as a little kid I still
remember being annoyed that I had to use
either like yellow or [ __ ] paying me
for my skin that matter busy making
[ __ ] motorcycles we have missiles on
them no people that well I drew like
dogs with no one's shooting they were
ridden by beasts so this product was
revealed recently in order to coincide
with the United Nations World Day for
cultural diversity for dialogue and
development where all the kids like
crayons were real all the crayons we
fighting each other inside Crayolas like
please yes good fight each other I'm
getting rich off of this [ __ ] I wonder
if they're gonna come up with like
pencils and like markers yeah what the
[ __ ] there's no using kids on this box
yeah kids that's marker representation
but no she's mmm what about clay hate to
hate to get too [ __ ] real I think
those exists what about clay bro okay
how to DJ saying that's what I've tried
to do I think they're so cool they're
the coolest people on well the only ones
cool enough to only have one headboard
that's true only people that can look
cool doing this yeah they don't even do
that anymore
now it just [ __ ] button whatever but
when they touch the knobs in the buds I
mean here's a change in music neither do
I know it's a sometimes it's Otto see
they sometimes it's a knee room you know
it's like a distortion situation yeah
but they're burning so many calories
it's like what the play is
so minimal I always always always felt
that they just had a pre-recorded track
and they're just pretending oh my no you
know doesn't all the celebrity DJs
that's the [ __ ] they're doing because I
was at one I was at an event with one of
the like he was a guy from some reality
show and he will be J for my boss DJ
Pauly B what's my idea was one of the it
was the Jenner the Jenner he was doing
DJ [ __ ] and then um he [ __ ] up he
didn't he broke the number one rule of
DJing he didn't plug it in no okay the
number two rule that everyone plays it
he let the music stop and everyone's
like oh like he was in the middle of
doing this [ __ ] and then the music
stopped it was like that's ultimate
power lowly like bring it down and it's
like intentional no no it was not that's
okay but yeah like a hard like back way
again yeah I didn't hear it no near that
I think that's like the DJ equivalent of
like lip-synching or I think you're
pretending to like hold interested
nothing happens I was everything at
playlist live in Florida it was an event
that one of the cool companies who
thinks they're really cool put on and it
was a bunch of [ __ ] influencer kids
and like please everybody welcome to
stage big moment Aaron Carter nobody
knew who the [ __ ] he was Aaron Carter
was there yeah and he did like a set up
on stage nobody gave a [ __ ] except for
me and Nicki and like two other couples
over there were they all ten year olds
yeah everyone there was like [ __ ] 15
16 years old he's used to having that be
a demographic but he forgot that I don't
think it was him I think he's just like
I'll take the check cool and then
they're like oh yeah this would be so
sick yeah my party Oh
the huge disconnect yeah couldn't even
name uh-oh I'd be check that's an air
Carter saw with the I want candy or some
[ __ ] yeah yeah you're a fan oh I guess I
am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]